[APPLAUSE]
JEFF HOWELL: Cool,
thank you everyone.
So, yeah, we're going
to talk about one
of my favorite topics,
which is retention.
And more importantly,
I would say engagement.
So maybe we'll just
start, as a quick preface,
I'll just use this
cool Jamboard.
I'm excited to use it on here.
So, you know, we've all
launched mobile games.
And there's sort of two
states that you can kind of
think of the world at.
You know, if this is just
sort of your revenue--
--revenue-over-time
type of thing.
So, what you unfortunately
see, a lot of games,
they sort of launch
like this, where,
you know, there's kind
of a bit of a spike,
and then they all fall down.
And then the first game update
comes, there's a little spike,
and then they sort of tail off.
And then you see
other games, that are
sort of up and to the right.
And, you know, the
difference between the two
is kind of just a short-term
retention problem.
These games that we call shark
finning, you know, they're sad.
But it's really a game
that just does not
have short-term retention.
So when you launch
a game like this,
the real question is: what
does your long-term retention
look like?
And that's the thing that we're
going to try to figure out
today.
So if I just clear this here.
So, the interesting
thing, when you
think about long-term
retention is,
what does that curve look like?
Does your curve kind of do
this, and continue to grow?
Does it sort of flatten out?
Or does it sort of die
off at a certain point?
And when you're trying
to plan a business,
from a business point of view,
this is really important,
because unfortunately, if
it's sort of the latter,
you end up with this,
what we call pie-plating.
So you end up launching
a game, and then it
kind of makes money, and
then it kind of dies off.
And then, hopefully you
launch another game in time,
so you sort of can
catch it again.
And so you're in
this horrible mode
of where you're trying to
continue to release product
just to keep your revenue flat.
Which, what you really
want is something
that looks like this, where you
launch one game, and it grows.
And then the next game
grows on top of it,
and you get this
sort of stacking.
And to do this, you really
need to understand what
long-term retention looks like.
So I said, most people fall
into this retention model
where it's
cohorted-based retention,
where everybody installs on D0.
If you come back on the
next day after that,
you're a D1 player,
and so on and so on.
And you kind of build
a graph of this.
And like I said, really
what does it look like?
Because you can't
really extrapolate these
graphs very well.
You don't know where
it's going to fall off.
Is it going to level
off at some point?
You know, what is a
good number for day 365?
Who knows, right.
It's really hard to extract
long-term retention out
of this.
So what most people end up
doing is they segment, right.
So they fall into
this trap here where
they go well, customers
are important,
so we're going to build like
a customer-based funnel.
So, you start off at the top
where people install the game,
and then there
might be an acquire,
they might have
finished the tutorial.
At some point they
come back the next day,
and they become a player.
Maybe they put
money into the game,
and they give you--
they're now a customer.
And they put more money in the
game, and you become a VIP.
And then, there's some
sort of perfect customer
that you're really looking for.
The real problem about
this is that these are not
service metrics.
These are retail metrics.
So, it's very akin to
old-school AAA, right.
The player is the person
that played the demo.
The customer is the person
that actually bought the game.
And then your VIP
is your collector.
He's the person who's got
the collector edition.
They got the DLC.
But mobile games are not this.
You know, mobile games
are a service, right.
And service metrics
are over time.
So it's really a lot--
I like using the bar example.
So, if I was running
Cheers, my primary interest
would not be how many people
bought a drink one night,
right.
It really is, how
many people come back
every single day, or
every single time,
and continue-- your repeat
customers, or your regulars,
right.
So we launched Contest of
Champions back in 2014,
and it's been our
strongest game ever.
It's gotten
phenomenal retention.
And what we started looking at,
was we tried to break that down
and figure out why this
retention was so good.
So the first thing we did is
we broke it up by how many--
metrics broken up by the
number of days of the week
that people play.
And what we found is, the people
that play seven days a week
look nothing like everyone else.
So, just in a matter
of engagement,
the number of
battles people play
a day, from a seven-day player,
is about two to three times
more than a six-day player.
And in fact, the six-day
player looks a lot more
like the five-day player than
it does the seven-day player.
And this also works for
monetization, too, as well.
If you sort of normalize it
off the one-day-a-week player,
as you'll see, the
seven-day-a-week players spend
almost five times more than
your one-day-a-week player.
So we said, I think we're
on to something here.
So what we ended up doing
is we looked at lapse rate.
So here's four different
games that we did.
They're all different genres.
They're all different
levels of success.
And we said, what is
the chance that someone
is going to churn the next week
after playing all seven days?
And what you realize
is, basically, zero.
I think on Marvel,
it's like 0.3 percent.
So it's really, really stable.
And it looks the exact
same for all these games.
They all look
very, very similar.
It's basically what we
call physics for retention.
So that gave this
concept of regulars.
So we say a regular
Kabam is somebody who has
played seven days consecutive.
And then, that's on a daily,
and then on a monthly,
it's 90% of the month,
so 28 days out of 31.
And so, in the regular base
model, it's much different.
And you can look
at it as a funnel,
but I think it's much better
off if you kind of draw this out
here, because that's
more like a state
machine than an actual funnel.
So at the end the day, what
you really want to get to
is your regular customers.
So, basically everybody
starts off as being a player.
They play the game,
they install the game.
Now, there's two ways you can
become a regular customer,
right.
So the first one is, you
can put money in the game
and you can be a customer.
And then after that, you end up
playing seven days consecutive.
The other way you
can do it is you
can go the other way around.
So you basically,
you're a regular now,
because you played
seven days, and then you
put money into the game.
So that's how you
enter the flow.
Now, once you're a
regular customer,
you're not always
a regular customer.
So for some reason,
you miss a day,
you kind of go off into
this other pool of being,
basically, non-regular again.
We call this being weakened.
But, if you end up
playing seven days again,
you can come back into the pool.
There's also the lapse
people, too, as well.
So if you end up not
playing at all for 14 days,
you can fall in this lapse pool.
But if you ever come back to the
game, you become regular again,
you can become a
regular customer again.
So this is really interesting
when you view it this way,
because when you think
about your business,
each one of these groups
need different things, right.
So a player that comes
in and gives you money,
now you try to
figure out how to get
them to play seven days a week.
These guys, they're obviously
playing seven days a week,
how do you then convert them?
For people that
have weakened, you
try to build game
designs and game
systems that are going to bring
them back seven days a week.
For people who
have lapsed, you're
going to try to reactivate
them to figure out
why they've lapsed, and
then try to turn them back
into customers.
So it's really like an
organic state machine,
and it's really important that
all the pieces fit together,
because what you realize when
you start digging into this is,
the majority of the
people go down this path,
and then it's pretty easy
to cycle people around here,
but if you're trying
to grow a business,
really the difference between
having more regulars than you
had yesterday is
really adding up
all these other little
percentages that you can get
throughout this entire funnel.
So what are the
power of regulars?
So in Marvel, over
90% of monthly revenue
now is through regulars,
and we're still growing them
three years into the game.
So year over year,
we've continued
to have our daily
number of regular users
continue to rise, even
three years into the game.
They end up having over a 97%
loyalty rate, which basically
means month over month, they
are continually coming back.
There's actually
months that we've
had over 100% loyalty
rate, which is crazy.
We've actually had cohorts
that are really old,
that actually are still
continuing to grow regulars.
And the beautiful
part of is, they
have a really stable
ARPMARC, which
is actually average revenue
per monthly active regular
customer.
[LAUGHTER]
So, sorry about that.
But ARPMARC, very
stable, which is great,
because if you're looking
to forecast your business,
you have a group of people
that never leave, and pay you
the same amount every month.
That's like, it's the
perfect forecasting tool.
So when we view this
for our business,
we really think about how we
can service these regulars,
and we think about
this regularity lens
throughout our entire business.
And so we've applied
this throughout
our entire operations.
So how can technology help?
So, I'm not going to
stress this any much,
but you just, you
need a good BI system.
Like data is the most imperative
part of this whole system.
You need to have multiple
components of it,
we can now walk through them.
So the first one that we really
think is super-important,
is we have this concept at Kabam
of the 360 view of the player.
So a lot of game companies
are only viewing their world
from what the player
does in the game,
and that's not the
entire picture,
Right So you have in-game
data, you have marketing data,
you have data from your
community, maybe your forums,
you have customer service.
What you really want
to do is view all that,
and get all that into
one spot, so you can
see the 360 view of a player.
At Kabam, like I said, we're
not go too deep in the deck
but, BigQuery is sort of
that center hub of our data.
We put a lot of
data into BigQuery.
On Marvel, you're looking around
1 and 1/2 petabytes of data
alone on there.
It's about 2 trillion rows.
We're ingesting three to
four billion events a day
on just one single game.
And the cool part is,
we've done table scans
where you get a billion rows per
second on a query performance.
So it's really quite impressive.
Then we just hook
it up to Tableau.
Great thing about Tableau
Online, it's sort of NoOps
as well.
Just like BigQuery,
you can hook it--
it integrates right
into BigQuery,
and we can build our
reporting on top of that.
The last little piece
is, this is obviously,
you know, the predictive--
predictive modeling
is the thing these days.
AIs, machine learning,
this is really
about you have this great
huge dataset, learn off of it,
train your models, and then
start predicting and making
predictions about the game.
And once you can
do that, you can
do some just really neat stuff.
So what we're going
to start talking about
is sort of the
top of the funnel.
So, people getting
into the game.
How do you get more
regulars into the game?
So, any game that
is successful is
going to end up doing
performance marketing.
So with performance marketing,
you're obviously buying ads
on different channels
and platforms,
they're coming into
the game, you're
able to attribute to them.
And then you can calculate
your yields, right.
So if your yields
are really based off
of how much money
you think you're
going to get out of this
person versus how much you
spent to acquire them.
The real [INAUDIBLE]
about that is yields
are very hard to calculate.
So often people get fooled.
Marvel is a really
interesting example,
because what we
saw, since Marvel
is a sort of, in some ways
it's a collection game, people,
what we would see is,
we'd have, actually,
these users that would
come into the game,
and they'd spend
like crazy until they
got all the champions that they
wanted, and then they'd leave.
And just sort of like, if you
can think of it like a numbers
point of view, you can
have a guy that comes in,
spends $1,000 in a month and
leave, well that's actually
not your highest LTV user.
What you'd much
rather have is someone
who spends $100 a month, and
does so for four or five years.
That's the type of user
you want to get to.
So if you just sort of optimize
all your ad spend based
off day 1 to day 7
yields, you can often
get fooled about actually
who your best users are.
And you're actually
not optimizing
well enough for your UA spend.
So this kind of
brought to this concept
that we have at Kabam
called auto-tune.
So what we end up
doing at Kabam,
is we have this system
called auto-tune,
where we basically,
we buy tons of ads,
and we spend money on them.
And then, once they get in the
game, and we've attribute them,
we have this machine
learning model
that can detect regularity.
And it can do it
really efficiently.
In fact, it only takes about
eight hours of actual time,
and we actually
know if someone's
going to be a regular in
three months from there.
And then what we do, is we
take that, we feed it back
into the machine, and we
can calculate return on ad
spend, we can calculate
LTVs based on this thing,
since we know the retention,
we know the [INAUDIBLE] marks.
And then we just
adjust our bidding.
So if we're getting
tons of regulars here,
we're going to throw
more money on here.
If we get less, we're
going to try less on here.
And then we can
say, we can optimize
all kinds of campaigns.
We end up having
thousands of campaigns
and different creative
running at once,
and then we just let
auto-tune optimize it for us.
And like I was saying,
it's really, really tight.
So this is a graph of the
difference in the score.
So we're about 95%, 90% correct
on predicting whether or not
somebody is going be a regular,
within eight hours, or not.
So it's a really, really
useful model for us.
And it works out
really quite well.
So the next part
in the whole thing
is sort of
strengthening players,
which is really turning
players into regulars, so.
Lots of books and
topics on this,
but it's really about
habituation, right.
Trying to make people
come back and do something
every day, tons
of books on this.
There's lots of different
ways to do that,
and we can talk
about a few of them.
So we believe at
Kabam, strongly,
that social gameplay is
one of the strongest ways
to get people to
play with each other.
A lot of these games are like,
from a neurochemical point
of view, are all
dopamine-type things.
When you start
adding social, you
start adding different
types of chemicals,
different types of
feelings into the game,
and you start adding
social pressure.
And that's why games like
World of Warcraft and such
have lasted for so long.
It's because people come
there, and it's a social event,
and people can still
play with their friends,
and that's what they want to do.
So from a technology
point of view, you know,
people on the internet
aren't always the best.
So when you start adding
chat and stuff like that,
it's really important that you
have a good filtering systems.
So as positive as a
experience can be,
it can also be horribly
negative, too, as well.
So it's really important that
you try to get that in there.
Adding group chat is great,
and self-regulating chats,
like alliance chats or stuff
like that, are also excellent.
And then bridging the gap.
If you can get real-time
chat translation there,
you can start doing
some really interesting
social interactions,
where you can actually
use territorial enemies that
can communicate with each other
to talk.
It's really, really interesting.
And then the next one
is really alliances.
So alliances, at
least in our games,
have just been
incredibly powerful.
If you just take the
short-term retention metrics,
the second someone gets in
alliances, their retention
basically triples.
So we always try to get
people into alliances.
Finding the right type of
alliance for people and stuff
is a very hard problem,
and is very interesting,
and you can get some
great work on that.
The social pressure
mechanism is really strong.
So if you build events
around cooperation,
or competitive loops
around getting people
to do things together, you
can get these great engagement
boosts.
The funny thing
about this, though,
is actually that also
the number one indicator
of churn prediction is actually
when you get kicked out
of your alliance.
So people who get kicked
out of the alliance,
we are on them right away to
get them into a new alliance
as fast as possible, because
that's the number one
predictor of churn in our game.
And then the next one is kind of
what we call putting on a show.
So we think, if you build a
game that someone can literally
play for 24 hours a day,
you will probably never
have any problem
monetizing them.
You just want to keep them
in the game as long as time.
We do not believe,
a lot of people
believe in this sort of concept
of like [? corps loop ?]
binging, and they can binge
too much, and they get fat,
and then they, they don't
want to play the game anymore.
Absolutely do not believe that,
have no data to prove that.
People can, if you give them
time to play, and they play it,
they will play it.
Its really about giving
people stuff to do.
So, if you kind of look
at what a week looks
like in the Contest
of Champions,
its all really about layering.
So we have about 100 events
a week that are planned,
and they all feed
into each other.
So you want to build a system
that can kind of like--
you can stack them.
So you can do a couple of
these events that give you
a rewards that go to
the next event, that
go to the next event,
that work on there.
There's different
types of events
for different types of people.
Some people play social
events, like the AVE/AVA.
Other people play single
events like PVP and grinding.
Giving all these
opportunities for people
to play these
different experiences
is really important.
And what we've done is we've
done a massive investment
in tools, it's our
back end called Sparx,
so that we can basically
allow live game
designers to tune the
game in such a way
that this is feasible.
And how we do it is largely
kind of four main areas.
So the first one is
really about targeting.
So having really strong
targeting capabilities
in your back end is
extremely important,
because what you can
do is, you obviously
have to do split testing, so
you can make these changes
and see how they happen.
You can end up cohorting
players into different things,
because someone who's
played the game for three
years versus some guy who
comes in a different game,
they're obviously going to
need to be cohorted in there.
You can do geotargeting.
Our back end has
but 200 dimensions
and more, actually now, of
targeting that we can add to.
And then you can also do
action-based targeting.
So someone does
something, and then it
changes how they handle it.
The next real strong thing that
we really are quite proud of
is this concept of
flexible economy.
So all these games, frankly,
are kind of similar.
They're all, where your money
is in all these games is having
a real strong meta-game system.
And a meta-game,
frankly, is really
quite simple at its core.
It's always you do
something, you do an action,
and you get something.
So you're always trading
one resource for another,
and there's an action
in between the lines.
So if you make that
generic enough,
you can make your entire economy
generic in a way that is just,
all you're doing is taking
this and doing something,
and turning it into that.
And if you build
tools around that
so that your live ops can
actually make new items,
and make new economies,
and shape them,
then you can do some
really powerful things.
And you can also measure
them, too, as well.
So our abstracted economy
ends up building a, basically,
an operation log for
every single action that
has an economic value to it.
So you have an oplog of every
single thing that happens,
and you can measure that,
which allows you to do
this cool stuff like this.
So if you're looking at it like
a single currency in the game,
you can actually see the flow of
currency and where it happens.
So you can see in
the middle there,
we saw this currency was getting
kind of high, so what we'll do
is live ops and we'll
maybe make a sink, which
might be like an event to
try to drain that currency,
and that will give you a
different currency, which
then they can make another
following event to drain it.
So you can really kind of move
your economy around in ways
that you can kind of
alter player behavior.
And then the real
part about this
is, anytime you get deep into
these data-driven analytics
and data-driven
systems, you really
need a way to manage it all.
So, in the Contest
of Champions, there's
about 200 to 300
megabytes of metadata
that people are always
handling and managing,
and you've got to build
tools around how you actually
move the different pieces across
different environments, how you
QA these, how you actually
merge them in and diff them,
and stuff like that.
And if you don't do that, you're
probably liable up for a mess.
I remember one
time in old Kabam,
before we had some
of these things,
we had built a gotcha box once,
and we didn't have these tools,
and it was a gotcha box that
opened 5,000 more boxes,
and it was sort of
Inception, and it
was a disaster to clean up.
So I can't stress
this enough how well
you need to have [INAUDIBLE]
about that stuff.
And then the last one is really
about long-term retention.
How do you retain
people for a long time?
So it's really all about knowing
when someone's going to leave.
You can pretty
much predict that.
Like I said, there's some
really strong indicators.
Getting kicked out of an
alliance is a huge one.
Velocity changes, of
how much they play
or how much they
engage the game,
always yields pretty
accurate results.
And then you kind of build,
you automate it then, right.
So you have the
machine learning models
that are running all the
time, generating fit scores on
whether or not someone's
going to churn.
If they end up going to churn,
then we'll start sending them
what we think they need,
they might be missing.
Maybe they'd been playing
in the game forever,
and they just, they haven't
got the character they wanted,
or they're running
out of currency.
We're going to try to give
them a win-back prize.
And if they don't
come, we'll take it
to the next-level
automation, that we're going
to send them an email, right.
If they don't come after that,
we'll send them a push message.
If they still don't
come after that,
we can actually
automatically put them back
into a UA campaign, and then
try to reactivate them that way.
And then we can use deep
linking to actually give them
reward through the UA campaign.
So having that whole
automated system
allows to claw back these
users that maybe left
because of whatever reason, they
maybe didn't have something,
could have been seasonality.
I mean, we got Pokemon
Go'ed a few years ago,
like everyone else did.
And they, you know, kind of
came back to us afterwards.
But we were able to claw
back a lot of the people
during that time.
And like I said,
it really works.
I think we've raised, with this,
our daily revenues by about 3%
to 5%, just with
the automated churn.
Hardest part about a
lot of these things
is trying to figure
out why they left.
Deciding whether or not they're
going to leave is pretty easy,
but if it's like
why, what do I need
to give you to make
sure that you come back?
And then with
re-activation campaign,
often when you're
doing lots of UA,
there is a certain
part, amount of spend,
that it's actually way
cheaper to actually try
to reactivate good users than
it is to go get brand new users.
So in a conclusion here,
really, it's all about
trying to avoid the shark fin.
Games that can grow, and have
done this holistic approach,
and use data to do that can
thrive for a very long time.
I'm pretty confident
that Marvel is
going to be a decade
game at this point.
Like I said, we're going
into our fourth year.
We're still continuing
to grow the business,
and grow our number of regulars.
And integrating the
technology around this really
allows you just to kind of
handle the player's lifestyle.
And like I said, every
single piece is important.
If you don't do all the pieces,
you'll end up kind of like,
everyday you're like-- it's
the difference between being
like 99.9% percent of the people
you had yesterday, or 100.1%.
It's just really that
close in a lot of cases.
And just closing the
loop on everything
is the way you do it.
Thank You.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: Thanks so much, Jeff.
Really appreciate it.
Can we get another round
of applause for Jeff.
He's [INAUDIBLE]